Hallo. Ja, hallo, guten Abend.
Guten Abend, Joseph ist mein Name. Ich bin der Diensthabender Arzt hier.
Nehmen Sie Platz, bitte. Ja, danke.
Erst mal, wie heißen Sie bitte? Mein Name ist Martin Hoffmann.
Martin, mit 1, 1 oder doppelt?
Mit 2, doppelt f und doppelt n.
Genau. Und Herr Hoffmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt. 40.
Und sonst sind Sie genau geboren? Am 1.7.1982.
1.7.1982. Alles klar. Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Hoffmann?
Ich bin 1,85 m groß. Ja, und wie viel wiegen Sie?
6,80 kg. Alles klar.
Herr Hoffmann, was fühlt sich zu uns? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Und zwar von den 3 Tagen habe ich starke Schmerzen in meinem ländenlöbensäunen Bereich.
Ja.
Und diese Schmerzen strahlen auch in meinem rechten Bein aus.
Strahlen nach rechten Bein?
Ja, in den rechten Bein.
Und können Sie sagen, können Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben, was für ein Schmerz?
Stechen der Schmerz?
Ich würde sagen, ein Zitterschmerz. Zit bis über den Fuß rein.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder kommen Sie wieder weg?
Die Schmerzen sind seit 3 Tagen dauerhaft da.
Die sind mal weniger, mal mehr, aber dauerhaft da.
Wo genau, im Länden, im Ganzenländenbereich, oder rechter Seite, oder linke Seite?
Ja, das kann ich nicht genau sagen, es ist halt mein Rücken.
Wenn wir uns also also unter dem Rückenbereich.
Und wenn Sie Ihre Schmerzen messen würden auf eine Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10.
Wie können Sie einschätzen, Schmerz?
Was bei Ihnen mit 1 bis 10 ist, die Schulnote oder, was ist 1?
Ich soll 1 bis 10 einschätzen, aber was ist, was soll das?
Das ist alles für am leichtesten Schmerz und 10 für unerträglichen Schmerzen entspricht.
Ja, dann würde ich so sagen, ein bisschen mehr als die Mitte, so 7 würde ich sagen.
7.
Strahlen nach rechten Beinen.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen verursacht, oder gibt es etwas,
dass die Schmerzen verstärken oder lindern?
Also, einen Abend zuvor, hatte ich meinem Freund beim Umzug geholfen,
haben wir Karton geschleppt und Möbel geschleppt.
Und am nächsten Tag, also vor 3 Tagen, am nächsten Tag hatte ich dann halt die starken Schmerzen.
Ich bin aber nicht gestürzt, sondern ich habe ein bisschen mit...
Aber haben Sie etwas Schweres geholt?
Ja, das war jetzt nicht sehr schwer, aber ich wollte nur umzugolfen.
Ja.
Es war jetzt kein Auto, etwas sehr Schweres, sondern das waren Kartons mit Büchern.
Kartons.
Öbelstücke.
Hatten Sie früher solche Schmerzen, oder ist das erstmal bei Ihnen aufgetreten?
Also schlimm, also man hat ab und zu mal so...
Ich tu es!
Sind Sie lehmiger, mein Herz, ja?
Hallo, Frau Asli, Frau Dr. Asli, danke.
Aber so schlecht war nicht, ne?
Nein, das war nicht so schlimm, aber diesmal ist es sehr schlimm, also es ist etwas anders.
Ja.
Waren Sie deswegen bei einem Arzt für diese Schmerzen?
Für die Schmerzen, nein, weil ich nicht beim Arzt gewesen war damals.
Das war ja so ein, zwei Tage und ist so stark, dann ging die auch wieder weg, ein Tag später.
Da hatte ich über Profäne eingenommen oder so mit Medikament und bisschen wärmen,
und dann war es gut, aber jetzt ist es ein bisschen anders.
Diesmal haben Sie etwas genommen und Schmerzen zu lindern?
Ja, über Profäne habe ich genommen.
Aber hat es Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, aber diesmal sind Sie trotzdem das Nerven, es hat ein bisschen gelindert, geschmerzt.
Ein wenig gelindert.
Ja, aber tut es immer noch weh?
Ja, das ist klar.
Haben Sie eine Schwellung oder andere Beschwerden beim Ihrem Bein, besonders aufrechten?
Nein, Schwellung habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie einen Temperaturunterschied?
Nein, ich habe keine Temperaturunterschied zwischen den Beinen.
Ne, habe ich nicht, denn die Temperatur ist in den Beinen gleich, ich habe keine Schwellung.
Oder Taubheitsgefühl?
Ja, an meiner Fußsohle, es ist taub.
Nur aufrechten sei.
Auf der rechten Fußsohle ist etwas komisch, ein pelziges Gefühl, ein bisschen taub.
Haben Sie auch einen Kribbeln, wie am Eisen laufen?
Kribbeln würde ich nicht sagen, nur dass ich das nicht richtig empfinden kann.
Ich kann zwar fühlen, aber meine linke Fußsohle ist sensibler.
Alles klar.
Leiden Sie an, zurzeit eingeschränkte Beweglichkeit?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht richtig nach vorne bücken, etwas zu geben.
Ich kann laufen, sitzen, stehen, geht schon.
Beim Aufstehen habe ich Schmerzen, bei belastenden Tätigkeiten habe ich mehr Schmerz,
aber ich habe keine Einschränkung der Beweglichkeit.
Also in der Ländelsohle schon, aber in meinen Beinen nicht.
Können Sie Ihre Rücken nicht beugen?
Nach vorne und nach hinten, wenn ich mich bewege, tut es weh.
Nach vorne beugen oder nach hinten überstrecken habe ich schon Schmerzen.
Ja, wegen der Schmerz.
Jetzt haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern bemerkt?
Herzrasen, Herzstolpern? Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Gut.
Oder Schlafprobleme beim Einschlafen oder Durchschlafen?
Ja, wegen den Schmerzen, da wache ich ein paar Mal auf, aber ich habe sonst keine Schlafstörung.
Leiden Sie eine Übelkeit oder Erbrechen zurzeit?
Nein.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt in der letzten 4 Tagen?
Nein, habe ich keinen Unfall gehabt.
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihre Vorgeschichte eine wichtige Krankheit, von der ich wissen sollte?
Leiden Sie unter chronischen Krankheiten, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder erhöhte Blutwertwerte?
Nein, ich nehme aktuell keine Medikamente ein.
Auch keine Erkrankungen?
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Reagieren Sie allergisch gegen Medikamente oder Nahrungsschlitten?
Ja, gegen Penicillin hatte ich meine allergischen Reaktion gehabt.
Den meiner Jugend.
Wie aussetzt sich die Allergie?
Damals hatte ich Luftnot, ich konnte nicht richtig atmen.
Luftnot, sehr gut.
wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, mein Mandelopie wurde mit 7 Jahren meine Mandeln entfernt.
Als Sie sieben waren?
Ja.
Ansonsten?
Ansonsten hatte ich keine Opies.
Herr Hofmann, rauchen Sie?
Rauchen? Nein, ich rauche nichts.
Oder hatten Sie schon mal geraucht?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Sehr gut, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, bei Gelegenheit trinke ich schon ein Bier, ein Flaschen Bier, ab und zu.
Bei Feiern oder bei Gesellschaftsabendumart vom Fernsehen auch.
Nicht jeden Tag, aber...
Wie oft?
In der Woche zum Beispiel.
Ja, 2-3 Flaschen, 2-3 Abende wird es schon sein.
2-3 Mal in der Woche?
Ja, Woche, alles klar.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Oh, Drogen, nee.
Das ist nur gut, ja.
Sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheiten und gegen Covid-19 geimpft?
Ja, ich habe alle meine Impfungen.
Sind Sie auch gegen Wundstaarkrampf geimpft?
Ja, ich habe auch.
Haben Sie zurzeit keine offene Wunder, ne?
Nein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Krankheiten, zum Beispiel bei Ihrer Mutter, Vater?
Meine Vater, soweit ich weiß, hatte eine Bluthochdruckerkrankung.
Leben Sie noch, ne?
Ja, die leben noch.
Das freut mich.
Das freut mich auch.
Kann ich die Ärger.
Und Ihre Vater leidet an Bluthochdruck und Ihrer Mutter?
Meine Mutter leidet an Zucker, also Diabetes.
Die nimmt da Medikamente ein.
Mit Insulinpumpe, wissen Sie, oder?
Ja, Medikamente nimmt sie da ein.
Die hat keinen Insulinspritz oder so.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister, ja. Ich habe eine Schwester.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Sind Sie verratet, Herr Hofmann?
Nein, ich bin nicht verratet.
Sind Sie ledig oder getrennt?
Ich lebe mit meinen Lebensgefährten zusammen.
Sehr gut. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Schlosser.
Haben Sie auch Sterst bei der Arbeit oder belasten Sie schwer auch bei der Arbeit?
Ja, aber manchmal muss man ein bisschen anfangen.
Manchmal muss man Metallstücke, Treppengeländer, Balkongeländer,
Teilstücke tragen.
Hochheben.
Es muss sehr schwer sein für Sie.
Es geht.
Umso schlimmer.
Ja, in der Vorhaltsstimmung habe ich gern gemacht.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine lange Reise gehabt?
Eine lange Reise, nee.
Eine lange Flugzeug.
Flugzeug, nee, ich habe keinen Urlaub gehabt.
Seit zwei Jahren seit Corona habe ich keinen richtigen Urlaub gehabt.
Alles klar.
Und jetzt haben wir unser Gespräch beendet.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Bandscheiben vorfall bei Ihnen.
Aber das bleibt nur natürlich ein Verdacht,
bis weitere Untersuchungen abgeschlossen sind.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach würde ich bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen und eine Röntgen durchführen.
Im Verlauf schauen wir, wie weiter geht.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Röntgen ist das Schlimm.
Eine schlimme Untersuchung.
Was kann man da sehen?
Röntgen ist sogenannte Durchleuchtung.
Vorteil ist, dass man sich von einem Leben oder
eine andere Zeit zu einem Leben erzielen kann.
Es beinhaltet ein bisschen Strahlung, aber die Dosis ist sehr niedrig.
Mit Hilfe dieser Strahlung sehen wir ein Bild von ihrer Körper.
Und natürlich schmerzlos.
Wenn es nicht genug sei, können wir auch eine Magnetik-Resonanz-Untersuchung
bei Ihnen durchführen.
Was haben Sie gesagt? Magnetik, ist das Magnetik?
Ja, Magnet-Resonanz, das heißt Kernspin-Untersuchung.
Weil Sie Magnetik gesagt haben?
Ja, Magnetik.
Magnet-Resonanz-Tomographie.
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Nein, ich wüsste nicht, was der Unterschied ist zwischen Röntgen-Untersuchung
und Magnets-Untersuchung.
Mit Hilfe der Röntgen haben wir nur ein Bild am fertigen.
Hallo?
Ja, jetzt hörst du wieder.
Ich höre Sie.
Entschuldigung, wegen meiner schlechten Verbindung.
Ja, mein Magnet-Resonanz-Tomographie, sogenannte Kernspin-Untersuchung,
das ist sowohl schmerzfrei als auch strahlenfrei Untersuchung.
Dafür müssen Sie für eine Zeit in einer Röhre liegen
und wir schneiden Bilder Ihrer Körper mit Hilfe dieser Computer.
Die Vorteile ist auch, dass wir gut beurteilen,
ob es Breit- oder Band-Scheiben-Felletzungen gibt.
Das ist die Gold-Standard für Ihre Bechwerden, besonders für Ihre Krankheiten.
Und warum machen Sie dann ein Röntgen? Was kann man da sehen?
Der Röntgen ist unser erster Wahl, aber im Verlauf können wir auch
ein Magnet-Resonanz-Tomographie durchführen.
Was kann man in einem Röntgen auf Band-Scheiben-Vorfall sehen?
Nein, nicht möglich.
Aber ich möchte sicher sein, dass es bei Ihnen keine Fraktur gibt.
Also erwarten Sie auch, dass hier Verdacht braucht, dass es ein Fraktur ist?
Ja, ich möchte auch ein Fraktur ausschließen.
Deswegen wäre es nützlich für Sie.
Okay.
Jetzt werde ich mit meinem Kollegen sprechen.
Danach sehen wir uns wieder.
Okay, danke.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Anscheinend gibt es keine Fragen.
Meine Seite auch nicht.
Also nur zur Ergänzung, Herr Dr. Jussch.
Ich würde nur den Übergang von der speziellen Anamnese
zum Allgemeinen Anamnese, war ein bisschen hart.
Ich würde da einen Satz noch hinzufügen.
Wir haben gesprochen über Bewegungseinschränkung.
Ich hatte gesagt, ich habe Schwierigkeiten durch Schmerz nach Beugen, nach vorne und nach hinten.
Dann haben Sie gesagt, okay.
Und irgendwas haben Sie dann gesagt, Übelkeit oder irgendwas.
Also die andere Anamnese.
Ich würde da sagen, okay.
Dann würde ich weitere Allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Ich würde auch andere Fragen stellen,
irgendwie einen Übergang machen sozusagen.
Aufmerksam machen, auf einmal fragt jemand mich.
Was ganz anderes.
Ich finde das schöner.
Also der Übergang.
Das man hat gesagt, okay, das habe ich jetzt fertig.
Und ich würde jetzt noch weitere Allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Ich würde es durch das Sie komplett klären lernen.
Und Sie hatten, das ist auch kein Fehler.
Aber es hört sich immer schön an, wenn Sie sagen, ja, wie geht es jetzt weiter.
Sie haben gesagt, ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ich würde den Wort ausführlich beifügen.
Ich würde Sie ausführlich körperlich untersuchen.
Hört sich besser an.
Es ist aber auch, wenn Sie nicht sagen, ist kein Fehler.
Aber dann haben Sie beim, ich werde eine Röntgen durchführen lassen.
Ich würde sagen, ich würde eine Röntgenuntersuchung durchführen lassen.
Röntgenuntersuchung.
Also dieses Wort Untersuchung hört sich auch besser an.
Nach meiner Meinung.
Ansonsten war erst mal alles okay.
Gut, von meiner Seite auch fertig.
Danke.
Das ist eine zweite Wahlgabe.
Eine Comput-Ein-CT oder eine CT-Tomographie.
Wenn man nur Tomografie sagt, dann weiß man, ob das eine Magnetoration
oder eine Magnetoration ist.
Oder eine Magnetoration ist eine Magnetoration.
Aber das ist auch eine zweite Wahlgabe.
Also die zweite Wahlgabe, die man auf der anderen Seite sieht,
ist eine Magnetoration.
Dann weiß man, ob es eine Magnetoration ist.
Aber es ist auch eine Magnetoration.
Es ist auch eine Magnetoration.
Ein
seitens man gefahren Kontrastmittel und aber die Darstellung der Wirbelsäule ist Mitte der
Wahl der MRT. Manche Leute können aber nicht, auf Vorteil ist es nicht strahlenbelastend.
Nachteil ist, okay, wenn mit mir die Regie war, schösch. Nachteil ist, dass man, wenn man
Platzangangs hat, nicht in die Röhre reingehen kann. Das dauert lang die Untersuchung, in der Regel 15
bis 20 Minuten. Beim CT ist es eine größere Röhre, eine flachere. Also es ist nicht, die Leute fühlen
sich nicht wie in einem Sack. Nachteil ist aber die Qualität der Aufnahme. Man kann zwar
manchmal erkennen, aber nicht sehr sensibel. Die Aufnahme ist nicht sehr sensibel. Anderer Fortnachteil
ist, MRT-Aufnahmen, die kriegt man hier in Deutschland nicht so schnell. Man ist privat versichert und
geht in einer private Radiologiepraxis. Und CT ist eine Aufnahme, die kriegt man zeitnah,
wenn man schnell Informationen haben will. Da kann man auch einen CT fahren lassen, damit man
schon ausschließen kann, ob ein Bandscheinvorfall da ist. Bei älteren Leuten zum Beispiel,
kann man nicht in einem CT immer genau sagen, ob es ein frischer Bruch ist zum Beispiel. Ein
ostipolizischer Fraktur, die Frischheit der Fraktur, die Aktualität der Fraktur,
kann man eher im MRT sehen, einer bestimmten Sequenz, weil dort die Idee in den Knochen zu sehen
ist und in den anderen nicht. Dann kann man sagen, ah, diese Fraktur ist besser. Also es
milder Wall in der Fotopädie-Urfaschur, also wenn es nicht um Frakturen geht, wenn es um
ein Weichteildiagnose geht, Bandscheinvorfall, Spinalkanalstehnose, Neuroforamenstehnose usw.,
dann ist mit der Wall des MRT. Dankeschön. Wenn wir anfangen, Jusuf? Ja, natürlich.
Ein Moment, bitte.
Wir laden Karol Gatina für die nennen Karol Wulosch-Wanathir.
So, jetzt bin ich wieder da.
Herr Obatz. Ja, bitte schön.
Ich habe eine neue Anamnese aufgehoben. Hatten Sie kurz für mich? Jawohl.
Herr Martin Hofmann, 40-jährige Patient, hat sich heute bei uns seit drei Tagen bestehende
Landenschmerz vorgestellt.
Im Landwirbelsäulebereich oder im LWS-Bereich, kann man auch sagen.
Ja, Schmerzen im Bereich vorgestellt. Die Schmerzen sind Ziele und Andauern.
Und die Schmerzen seit vier Tagen, vor vier Tagen,
während einem Umzug beim Schwer-Kisten-Hebung getreten.
Früher hat nicht so eine Schmerz.
Aktuell nimmt er im Profil ein Milligramm, welche ihm die Runde braten.
Ich habe Akustik nicht gehört.
Das Internet ist jetzt nicht so gut, deswegen entweder von Ihnen oder von mir.
Ich habe 800, welche ihm ein bisschen Linderung gebracht hat.
Und als Symptome klagt er über hipestis an rechter Fußsäule
und in Geschrägung beim Rücken nach vorne beugen, wegen der Schmerzen.
Wie würde man das nach vorne beugen, nennt man?
Rückenflektion.
Nach vorne und nach hinten sozusagen.
Nach vorne ist eine Inklination.
Und nach hinten ist eine Reclination.
Hallo, hören Sie mich?
Jetzt hör ich.
Vielleicht, wenn Sie wollen, können Sie Ihre Video ausschalten.
Dann ist die Frequenz, die Übertragung besser, glaube ich. Kann sein.
Video kaputt ist oder?
Wenn es für Sie keine Umstände macht?
Nein.
Ja, Ihnen da.
Soll auch schon.
Ich habe die Epsen und haben du ja nicht.
Ja.
Okay.
Nach vorne beugen ist eine Inklination.
Und nach hinten, Überstreckung nach Dorsal, ist eine Reclination.
Also hat er eine Reclination und ein Inklinationsschmerz.
Im Bereich der Lendenbüro-Solode oder im Bereich der LBS.
Ja.
Und die Fragen nach Schwellung, Parästhesie,
Brust oder Kopfschmerzen oder Unfall wurden verneint.
Die Vegetation am Nese ist bis auf Insomnia,
wegen aktuellen Schmerzen unaufwändig.
Ist bei ihm kein Vorerkrankung bekannt.
Eine Adenektomie wurde bei ihm im Alter von 7 durchgeführt.
Tonselektomie, meinen Sie?
Ja, Tonselektomie.
Nehmt zuzeit oder regelmäßig keine Medikamente ein.
Nur Ibuprofen 3-mal bei Bedarf.
Es ist eine Penicillin Allergie bei ihm bekannt.
Welche Dispner äußert sich?
Welche als Dispner?
Noch mal den Satz bitte.
Ja, die Penicillin Allergie.
Penicillin Allergie und Allergie äußert sich als Dispner.
Ja, okay.
Er ist nicht raucher und trinkt Alkohol 3-4-mal in der Woche.
Er ist voll geimpft.
In der Familienanamnese zeigt sich Atelier Hipertoni
beim Vater und Gebetis Melitus bei der Mutter.
Er hat eine gesunde Schwester
und die Sozialanamnese zeigt.
Hat der Kinder?
Hat der Kinder.
Ich werde beim Köpferlich-Untersuchung fragen.
Okay, okay.
Er ist nicht verheiratet, lebt zuzeit mit ihrem Lebensgefährten
und arbeitet als Schlosser
und habe auch Belastung bei der Arbeit
mit schwierigen Sachen heben.
Und Reis an Amnese ist unauffällig.
Ich muss den Obungen genannte beschwerden.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf, Discus prolapsus,
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommt LWK-Fraktor in Betracht.
Um mein Verdacht zu weiterer Abklärung,
würde ich diese Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich würde den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Danach würde ich Röntgenländenbereich durchführen.
Und gegebenenfalls ein MRT der betrofene Seite.
Wenn Sie eine Röntgenuntersuchung machen lassen,
zum Radiologen den Auftrag geben,
was steht dann als Auftrag drauf?
Röntgenländenbereich in zwei Eben.
Genau, Röntgenländenbereich in zwei Eben, richtig.
Weiter?
Es gibt eine Blutentnahme gegebenenfalls,
wenn eine Operation erforderlich ist.
Die geründungswerte Blutbild-CRP.
Würden Sie abnehmen?
Ja, gegebenenfalls am Ende MRT-Untersuchung des Ländenbereichs.
Warum würden Sie eine Blutgruppe-Untersuchung machen lassen?
Es ist ein Rieseneingriff.
Würde man sehr viel Blut verlieren?
Wenn beide Patienten eine Operation erforderlich sei.
Ich denke nicht, dass wir sie wechseln können.
Eine Blutgruppe bei Brauchoperationen und schon,
wo man bei der Gefäßoperation und so weiter,
bei einer Herzoperation,
bei einer Ländenbüfe,
wie bei den Minimalinvasiv,
mit einem kleinen Schnitt mit Mikroskopisch,
gehen wir da rein.
Da blutet es zwar, aber da braucht man nie Fremdblut.
Seitdem kommt es ein älterer Mann,
der hat ein HB von 8 und wir wollen operieren,
da kann man darüber diskutieren,
ob man vor der Narkose noch E-Cars gibt oder nicht.
Alles klar.
Er ist 40 Jahre alt, aber auch keine Blutgruppe zu bestimmen.
Okay.
Wenn mein Verdacht sich bestätigt,
würde ich diese Therapeutikmaßnahmen empfehlen.
Konservativtherapie, zum Beispiel mit Anergetikum,
Physiotherapie und Vermeidung von schwerer Hebungen.
Und als Operativtherapie gegebenenfalls Diskectomy kann man machen.
Okay.
Wenn die Idealisation da wäre,
wenn Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung,
wann würden Sie bei einer körperlichen Untersuchung,
das wissen Sie jetzt noch nicht,
aber wenn Sie körperlichen Untersuchungen,
was wäre ein Kriterium, wo man sagt,
man soll operieren?
Wenn bei der patienten Harn in Kontinenz gibt es...
Zum Beispiel, oder...
Es ist ja nicht immer ein Harn in Kontinenz,
es ist immer abhängig, welche Etage es betrifft.
Also nicht jeder, der Bandscheinvorfall hat
und der man operieren muss, hat Harn in Kontinenz.
Das wollte ich sagen.
Da stimmt, wenn Harn in Kontinenz ist
oder wenn was noch wäre,
dass mehr passiert hat.
Teilpreisgefühle?
Nein, nicht zwingend,
sondern eine Parise.
Parise.
Wenn eine Parise vorliegt,
dann sollte man auch...
gibt es verschiedene Grate,
50, 40, 30, 50 und so weiter.
Aber bei einer Parise sollte man eine Operation
zumindest denken, sozusagen.
Aber das weiß man nur,
wenn eine körperliche Untersuchung durchgeführt wird.
Das können Sie jetzt noch nicht wissen,
wenn Sie noch nicht untersucht haben.
Okay, dann...
Dann habe ich Behandelt.
Okay, das ist okay.
Ich habe nichts großartiges hinzuzugeln,
sozusagen.
Haben Sie selber noch Fragen?
Selber jetzt nicht.
Okay, gut.
Hat in der Gruppe jemand eine Frage?
Vielleicht wäre...
habe ich eine wichtige Frage verpasst?
Eigentlich nicht.
Sie haben ja...
Die Grundregel war ja immer diese PTMS.
Also die Durchblutung haben Sie ja gefragt,
ob eine Temperatur-Unterschieds-Zweidextremität...
Sie müssen da nur sagen,
ein bisschen genauer sagen.
Jeder weiß dann, temperaturisch ist sie zwischen uns beiden
oder zwischen...
Was?
Das haben Sie danach ergänzt.
Also, dann ist es motorisch.
Sie haben gefragt, ob Sie irgendwelche Bewegungseinstehung haben,
aber nicht genau gesagt, ob Sie Kraftverlust haben.
Das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen genauer.
Natürlich, wenn ich eine Paräse habe,
habe ich auch eine Bewegungseinstehung.
Aber ich kann ja auch durch meine Schmerzen
eine Bewegungseinstehung haben.
Deswegen kann man sagen, haben Sie ein Kraftverlust an den
Muskulatur, das wäre vielleicht noch.
Und S-Sensibilität haben Sie ja gefragt.
Das war ja eine Hypesthesie,
also eine Taubheit in meiner Fußsohle.
Für welche Niveau meinen Sie?
Wenn man sagt, Taubheitsgefühl an der Fußsohle.
Wissen Sie, welche kurze Komplition wäre?
Zivf.
Nee, Fußsohle.
C ist Cervical.
S-Siv.
Nee, es gibt ja Lendenwürme-Syllog.
Und dann meistens sind es L1, 2, 3, 4, 5
und S1.
L5, S1, ich meine.
S1 ist der Nervenwurzel.
Der Matum S1 ist Fußsohle.
Aber nicht schlecht, das ist gut.
Mussten Sie nicht wissen.
Das ist ein Fachwissen.
Das ist nicht relevant für Ihre Prüfung.
Man kann auch manchmal sagen,
falls eine neurologische Auffälligkeit ist,
würde ich den Patienten noch den neurologen vorstellen.
Ich würde den Patienten untersuchen
und eventuell eine konseggeladische Vorstellung
bei einem neurologen machen lassen.
Okay, dog, sonst.
Herr Prof. Mahmoud.